après avoir fait état de 39 cas de
contaminer au coronavirus le ministère
de la santé vient d'annoncer un nouveau
bilan 50 cas de contamination en
coronavirus une personne de 70 ans est
décédé hier suite à cette infection est
une personne guérie après avoir été
admise à l'hôpital et présentant des
signes de contamination pour le
professeur alaïa membre de
l'observatoire des maladies émergentes
et attaché au ministère de la santé
l'heure est à la prévention car la
tunisie a peur de ne pouvoir faire face
si une épidémie devenait beaucoup plus
généralisée je vous propose d'écouter le
professeur en fait tu elle ment c'est le
respect de l'auto et seulement qui est
la mesure la plus efficace pour le en ce
moment s'il aura un confinement de
certaines zones sont jugées à risque
d'extension du virus ça sera à fait
comme vous le savez le système de santé
publique il y a plusieurs insuffisances
ça dépend la capacité dans le secteur
public
elle est actuellement identifiées mais
on compte beaucoup aussi sur le
partenariat public privé pour assurer la
prise en charge des patients graves pour
le moment on a donc on capacités qui
n'est pas très important tout le monde
sait que par rapport à cette capacité on
a de quoi hospitalisé un nombre de
sujets graves dans les centaines avec le
secteur privé
on peut assurer un nombre plus important
espérons que nous mettons tous les
moyens pour la phase actuelle pour
éviter l'extension et éviter
l'apparition de cas graves
c'est une phase cruciale dont la nôtre
lutte contre l'extension du coronavirus
le gouvernement tunisien a pris ses
dispositions pour lutter contre la
propagation de ce virus
un couvre-feu a été mis en place depuis
mardi soir 18h interdisant toute
circulation dans le pays
évitant les tunisiens à rester confinés
déjà il ya quelques jours le
gouvernement avait déjà pris et d'autres
mesures fermes en les restaurants les
cafés les bars et ce à partir de 16h
pour éviter tout rassemblement qui
pourrait conduire à une augmentation de
la contamination des frontières
maritimes ont été fermées les frontières
aériennes également surtout avec
l'italie aucun vol n'était assuré avec
la france l'espagne l'allemagne ou
encore la grande-bretagne et les vols
ont été nettement réduits l'heure est au
confinement l'heure est à la prévention
le gouvernement souhaite limiter la
propagation de ce virus